hello everyone so long story short my
security clearance is not adequate for
the anomaly you're being briefed on
today so mobile task force commander
Robert hunt will be covering the
briefing after I get a few systems up
and running anyway I'll see you all
later and I hope you learn something
good bye thank you
dr. Miller can you confirm that asset is
online and scramble version 2.1 has been
initialized thank you let's begin
item number scp-096
object class Euclid special containment
procedures
scp-096 is to be contained in its cell a
five meter cubed airtight steel cube at
all times weekly checks for any cracks
or holes are mandatory there are to be
absolutely no video-surveillance or
optical tools of any kind inside scp-096
is cell security personnel will use
pre-installed pressure sensors and laser
detectors to ensure scp-096 is presence
inside the cell any and all photographs
video or recordings of scp-096 is
likeness are strictly forbidden without
approval from dr. 405 description
scp-096 is a humanoid creature measuring
approximately two point three eight
meters in height subject shows very
little muscle mass with preliminary
analysis of body mass suggesting mild
malnutrition arms are grossly out of
proportion with the rest of the subjects
body with an approximate length of 1.5
meters each skin is mostly devoid of
pigmentation with no sign of any body
hair scp-096 is jaw can open to four
times the norm of an average human other
facial features remain similar to an
average human with the exception of the
eyes which are also devoid of
pigmentation it is not yet known whether
scp-096 is blind or not it shows no
signs of any higher brain functions and
is not considered to be sapient scp-096
is normally extremely docile with
pressure sensors inside itself
indicating it spends most of the day
pacing by the eastern wall
however when someone views scp-096 is
faced whether it be directly via video
recording or even a photograph it will
enter a stage of considerable emotional
distress scp-096 will cover its face
with its hands and begin screaming
crying and babbling incoherently
approximately one to two minutes after
the first viewing scp-096 will begin
running to the person who viewed its
face who will from this point on be
referred to as scp-096 one documented
speeds have varied from 35 km/h 2 km/h
and seems to depend on the distance from
a cp0 96:1 at this point no known
material or method can impede scp-096 s
progress the actual position of scp-096
1 does not seem to affect scp-096 s
response it seems to have an innate
sense of scp-096 one's location
note this reaction does not occur when
viewing artistic depictions see document
0 9 6 1
documentation zero nine six one of
experiment zero nine six one experiment
zero nine six one is headed by dr. Dan
purposes to test scp-096 his abilities
while obtaining complete physical
description of scp-096 D 903 one is a 32
year old convicted felon and former
tattoo artist D 903 one is placed inside
bathysphere 303 a which is then lowered
in the Tonga trench off the coast of New
Zealand position is approximately
kilometers from a CP 0 9 sixes temporary
containment cell at site the following
was recorded via video surveillance
inside bathysphere 303 a between it and
doctor Dan's control site on the New
Zealand mainland bathysphere 303 a
reaches final depth of ten thousand 800
meters expected now on your left you
should see a steel container open it and
there will be a manila folder holding
several photographs D 903 one complies
the camera is located so the photograph
can not be seen thank you please set
this photograph facedown in the
receptacle to your right and look at the
next photograph describe it
[Laughter]
at this point approximately 1332
Standard Time dr. Dan and experiment
control is notified that a CP 0 9 6 is
breached containment the fastest path to
scp-061 has been cleared of civilians
and other image capturing devices and
scp-096 is now being tracked by
satellites by a tracking collar
[Music]
scp-096 one mumbles and expletive and
spends the next 20 minutes drawing a
sketch of the photograph at the time of
completion
scp-096 is confirmed to be kilometers
away from a CP 0 at 6 1 and close the
door
scp-096 1 complies and the sketch leaves
bathysphere 303 a in a watertight
buoyancy container the other photographs
are then incinerated in the onboard
incinerator 40 minutes pass scp-096 is
now confirmed to be at scp-096 ones
position and is diving transponder
signal ends in 9339 meters as pressure
goes beyond the device's operational
limits the camera shows the bathysphere
shaking slightly from scp-096 ones
reaction it is assumed as CP 0 9 6 is on
the hull and is visible through the V
port
video and audio feed is cut as the hull
of bathysphere 303 a is breached
scp-096 is recovered by surface recovery
team foxtrot 303 a without incident the
sketch of scp-096 is also recovered and
a quick test confirms no hostile
reaction from a CP 0 96 sketch is sent
to experiment control on New Zealand
while scp-096 is moved to permanent
containment upon arriving at scp-096 1's
location scp-096 will proceed to kill
and scp-096 1 100% of cases have left no
traces of scp-096 1 scp-096 will then
sit down for several minutes before
regaining its composure and becoming
docile once again it will then attempt
to make its way back to its natural
habitat
due to the possibility of a mass chain
reaction including breach of foundation
secrecy and large civilian loss of life
retrieval of subject should be
considered alpha priority
doctored has also petitioned for
immediate termination of scp-096 see
interview zero nine six one order was
awaiting approval termination order has
been approved and is to be carried out
by dr. C incident zero nine six one a so
containment has been attained yes
doctor let me see the security footage
begin lock a large steel cube is shown
in the middle of a research lab which is
teaming with a dozen or so researchers
in view of the camera is a control booth
displaying readings from various sensors
inside the cube fast forward one minute
32 second the control booth operator
leans forward alerted to the various
readings on the sensors approximately 5
seconds later a steel wall on the
containment cube receives a sizeable
dent bending outward the dent becomes
larger before breaking scp-096 is seen
bending the steel away frantically
trying to escape
emergency plates drop on the cube as a
containment breach is sounded the
security tape has scp-096 his face
blurred out as per containment protocol
two security teams enter the room as
scp-096 breaks out of containment live
rounds and tranquilizer darts are fired
to no visible effect approximately 90%
of researchers and security personnel
have directly viewed scp-096 his face
and a code Lima is declared the room and
surrounding areas are sealed and flushed
with last nerve agent approximately 2
minutes later
scp-096 breaches research site and
traveled kilometers through the outside
desert traveling and log that go Romeo
was assigned into immediate containment
bridge when we realized just how big a
breach we were dealing with we were
completely overwhelmed funny how the
best and brightest minds in the world
can be so unprepared so you're saying
it's your own fault absolutely not this
was a new discovery in scp-096 behavior
we had no way to know
and we were lucky it didn't turn into an
XK begin lock helm cam footage for me r1
footage from inside a uh-60 shows us CP
0 96 on a desert floor moving in a
considerable speed this is echo Romeo
actual we have visual of the target and
equip the RA listens to the radio as
orders are related scp-096 can be seen
slowly gaining speed erm motions
off-camera the l3 appears holding a
modified XM 500 anti-materiel rifle two
shots are fired the first misses and the
second hits scp-096 in the lower leg
scp-096 stumbles but recovers speed
changes insignificant they are a motions
- we are three again er three fires
three more shots the first to miss and
the third hits scp-096 in the head
scp-096 falls skids and rolls several
times reducing its speed minimally
scp-096 rolls to its feet and continues
unabated camera pans up to c8 v-22
Ospreys belonging to mobile task force
tower one flying overhead and past the
helicopters on the same outbound vector
as scp-096 camera comes out and log
begin lock video interview log 0 9 6 1a
dr. Alexi appears very calm and
determined announces all questions
slowly and deliberately where were you
exactly at the time of the breach or
break getting a cup of coffee it was
pure luck it wasn't caught in the
containment area describe your actions
directly after the containment breach a
sentinel romeo after scp-096 and a loved
it of the band to the situation within
set upon the task of locating scp-096
one once the general direction of
scp-096 was determined i said the mobile
task force now wanna head to evacuate
civilian population centers in a series
in lansing suspend all according to
containment protocol end log begin lock
dr. Daniel Dan sits patiently on the
table in front of him is what looks to
be a set of modified night-vision
goggles further right where were you
exactly during scp-096
containment bridge in the mountain range
trying to find more information on
scp-096 his origins was a quick research
expedition so I left dr. Alexia charge
of containment he is competent enough if
a bit eager and he has proved himself in
the past this is all confirmed by the
various related paperwork said uncle
think it was just for the record dr. now
knowing that a CBC of about six is
immune to all known forms of damage
while in an enraged state why would you
order the sniper attacks from the
emergency response team why not
if there was a chance to slow down at CP
0 9 6 and give more task force to have
one more time than we had to try it
I put the yarn no danger and the
choppers were in danger of being outrun
anyway honestly PR could do little else
to help or harm the situation I see now
can you explain this interview emotions
to the goggles lying on the table yes
this is project scramble and eyepiece we
assigned to D D our mobile task force
tell one designed by dr. Alex he and
myself specifically Percy Peter 5:6
it carries a small microprocessor which
constantly analyzes the viewing field
for the facial features of scp-096
facial recognition software inside
instantly identifies them scrambling the
image into an unrecognizable mess before
the light reaches the human eye 20 genes
really expensive theory which is why
it's such a shame make it work
end look begin log audio transcript
between mobile task force tower 1 and
modified EG 3 century a WACS callsign
Big Brother house breathe in the air
moving a waiting vector electronics
online cruising altitude reached
uploading programs scramble to all
camera systems cameras online
Big Brother is now watching what
outbound vector is the target currently
heading target is currently westbound
traveling on [ __ ] yeah he's on the i-40
I think he just flipped a semi album
vector is degrees by next town on the
vector I'd say a couple hundred
kilometers [ __ ]
MTF we're suggesting echo Romeo begin
evacuating the i-40 I don't know how
many cars the target is wrecked
told one that's a negative Big Brother
er is reporting that the target is out
running her choppers they can't get
ahead of him then get them to stop the
motorists on the other Lane I don't know
how many people have seen this thing's
face end log the first three elements of
tower one succeeded in gathering the
town's folk in the first three towns
without incident
scp-096 one was confirmed not to be in
any of these when scp-096 ran through
each in turn without stopping however a
video log in n TF tower shows scp-096
one being identified in the town and the
ensuing incident show it begin log pound
cam footage from element four of mobile
task force tower one in the town of
stone most of the town's people are
gathered in the square
all blindfolded helicopters sweep the
town indistinct orders are heard over
the loudspeakers from both the
helicopters and the ground personnel
[Music]
[Applause]
approximately two kilometers away
scp-096 is seen to be coming over the
crest of the hills it tries to slow down
on the descent
but trips and tumbles down at high speed
crashing through several houses before
regaining its footing almost without
delay
[Applause]
several shots are heard none of which
are directed at scp-096 scp-096 stops
for one second before running into the
crowd of townsfolk throwing many aside
and trampling more more shots are heard
as the crowd begins dispersing the
loudspeakers unintelligible under the
vocalizations of scp-096
scp-096 locates scp-096 one a
middle-aged man and the camera views
scp-096 grabbing him before it is hit by
a fling townsperson
and is dislocated from the helmet end
log begin lock video interview log 0 9 6
1 C I was looking for CP 0 9 6 Intel 3
loss water hostage was a semi-pro
mountainy to contribute it hardly took a
snapshot mask and just happened to catch
scp-096 in the background
Wilfred holds up four fingers for
emphasis 4 pixels for [ __ ] pixels I
don't think I even knew what I saw it
was probably just looking at the picture
one day noticed it off cold Potter star
I went on with his day how did you find
it
now a scramble yeah picked it up
straightaway the lieutenant got the
picture and took you down to the chopper
before I ever got to see it by then the
damn monster taken down big brother
peeled open the format major strike all
hell was breaking loose
so the scramble gear was ineffective
ineffective they bailed unscramble the
pieces of [ __ ] that killed the whole
dumb task force
you know only three people who were
alive besides me all because some [ __ ]
eggheads so especially our count them as
into scp-096 is hostile reaction
those bloody idiots gonna put a bike
over the Tommy's head I've been doing
with it but no we are you stay on the
scramble and look begin log call me
interviewee begins shouting and cursing
do we need to administer a sedative
no now I apologize parable was a really
ingenious idea however it was a failure
because we did not fully know how I see
these young 9:6 worked easy as the chip
inside scramble picked up scp-096 his
facial features and began scrambling
them there was a split-second of
uninterrupted light flow to the retina
computers are fast but not as fast as
light so there's a split second image of
scp-096 his direct face sent to the
brain it wasn't even consciously
received but apparently it was enough to
trigger the hospital reaction in scp-096
so with the report of this photograph
that's the most disturbing part of this
whole incident you know that the former
scp-096 one went on his mountain trip
1990 that's years of that photo hanging
there before he saw ICP 0 9 6 since the
brain doesn't need to be aware that it
is viewing scp-096 his face to trigger
the reaction than to be ticking time
bombs hidden literally anywhere in the
world how many photographs are out there
containing a CB 0 9 6 just doing them
notice waiting for a careful eye as I
said before I want this neck terminated
now and look just a quick question
doctor um what exactly were you planning
on doing their major Jack Wilfred was
top-notch SBS when we recruited him
I was also a recon horbet sir and I was
deployed at the causes Marines bsp no
they enough both of you
moving on begin log video interview log
zero nine six one day yes you told me
that could you tell me exactly what
transpired was done with all it and it
was sitting there in the highway just
got done ribbon up in a minivan
interviewee is silent and I'm where's
landed the chopper I got out and back
kappa the bag over its head it got
common they took me so the victims in
the minivan were the last two of you
deceive easier nine six interface
interviewee is silent
interviewee remains silent for the
remainder of the interview and was
released he was later found in his bunk
room having committed suicide via
hanging with a makeshift rope a half
crushed pacifier was found in his fist
end log
begin log video log 0 96 1d confiscated
tape from news broadcast CNN the image
shows first responders surrounding the
remains of a crashed plane over the
shoulder of the field reporter the plane
which seems to be military in origin has
no outward markings designating it as
part of the US military while first
responders look for a black box
recording it is thought by police that
the plane crashed due to a massive cabin
breach in both the cockpit and fuselage
the report emotions to a large hole in
the side of the plane which several
firefighters are climbing inside
paramedics have found only three bodies
which is odd for a plane apparently
requiring a crew of around 20 men police
had suggested the reporter is cut off as
three super stallions are shown hovering
overhead two of which land and begin
unloading troops belonging to mobile
task force epsilon n log begin lock so
are we finished here one last question
doctor are saying it as it seems we find
it interesting that there is no brain
trauma research site or coffee
the interviewee remains silent we think
it would be best if you begin talking
remainder a video interview log 0 9 6 1
a redacted end look I don't see what
that has to do with me there's no reason
to play dumb doctor he's told us
everything well then I guess there's no
use in feigning anything is there
audio recording low-five hearing upon
reviewing your testimony and available
footage in the confession of the late
dr. Alex II it is the unanimous
agreement of the old five that you are
to be terminated for your part in the
gross breach of @cp 0 96 and I thought
you would know the meaning of for the
greater good
do not try my patience doctor given the
incidents scope and potential deal 5
have approved your request for
termination of scp-096 given the lack of
personnel with understanding of the CB 0
96 the termination will be entrusted to
you under heavy guard in the personal
supervision of me your own termination
will be scheduled at a later date and
look that's horrible doctor how could
you know any worked there was only a
matter of time until that happened at a
major population center in his face
spread all over the news
I can kill 0 96 but I've killed myself
in the process
Audio log from interview 0 9 6 1
interviewer ducted interviewed retired
captain former commander of retrieval
team Zulu 9 alpha retrieval incident 0 9
6 1 a begin lock they told us to bag
attack didn't tell us jack [ __ ] look at
the devil could you describe the mission
please yeah yeah sorry we had two
choppers one with my team we spotted the
target about two klicks north of our
patrol path I'm guessing he wasn't
facing in our direction they would have
taken us out that in there and your
report says scp-096 didn't react to the
cold it was minus degrees Celsius
actually it was - and yes it was but
maybe it didn't do so much as shiver
anyway we landed approach the target
god we did it back that's what dr. I
turned to answer it and that's what
saved me it target must have turned in
my own squad side
that's when scp-096 entered an agitated
emotional state yep sorry got the
willies for a second
that's alright yeah well I never saw his
face my squad did they paid for double
yes could you describe it a little more
please
yeah yeah it started screaming at us and
crying not animal roaring though sounded
exactly like a person really [ __ ]
creepy
we started fire anyone it picked up
corporate ripped off his leg screaming
for help anyway we were blowing chunks
out of the dark round after round didn't
do jack [ __ ] I almost lost it when it's
done that's when he ordered the use of
an 84 hdt launcher and that I tank gun
started carrying it ever since the
series of colors I've seen those things
tear through tanks like tissue paper did
the same thing to the target there was
significant damage to a CB 0 96 that
didn't even flinch the cafetaria part my
squad but with half of its force Oh God
but was it taking damage if it was it
wasn't showing it
it must have lost all its organs always
blog but admitting knowledge any good
bone structure wasn't heard at all
though it can tear my squad apart so no
actual structural damage how many rounds
would you say were fired at scp-096 at
least a thousand our door gunner kept
this deal 19
for at least 20 seconds 20 seconds
that's 650 caliber rounds pumped into
the favour might as well been spitting
at it this is when Zulu 9b arrived yeah
yeah my squad was gone
Zulu 9 be managed to get the bag over it
said and it just sat down we got it into
the chopper and got it here I don't know
how I never saw his face maybe God but
uh whoever thought I should live gee I
guess that we have obtained an artist's
depiction of scp-096 his face what do
you like to view it you know after
hearing that thing screams
and the screams of my men I don't think
I want to put a face to what I heard no
just no
all right I believe we're done here
Thank You captain
let this be on record that I'm formally
requesting scp-096 be terminated as soon
as possible and look
27 there have been 27 attempts on a cp0
nine-sixes life in the past six months
all directed by the man who set him free
dr. Daniels Daniel's for his partner
spent the last six months in a Cell on a
good day he is escorted to the testing
chambers to oversee an attempt and then
back to that cell his termination has
been delayed in order to allow him to
oversee the destruction of a cp0 96 but
the oath iams are losing their patience
dr. Daniels is a condemned man but if
all he can do is fail well they have
plenty of other people who can handle
this project he has a month left
regardless of his results at the end of
that month he will be terminated these
are his last days and last attempts to
take a cp0 96 with him
I would like to give a special thank you
to the Morrigan geum's Sabha arbiter
Sewell Darius
Thanh Justin day der naam Joker Corvis
and jayvo Jack Corey Parker escrow knock
on utens quad if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos found some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you